This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. I've been working in radio a long time. It's been so long that when I first started out, I did all my interviews on cassette tape. I'm a RANCE PMD-222 to be exact. I have a soft spot for cassettes and that machine in particular. But honestly, cassettes never really sounded all that great. So it was assumed that people would use cassettes for voice recordings, things like reporters using them in the field. That's Mark Masters.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。我做广播很久了。时间久到我刚开始入行时，所有的采访都是用磁带录音的。准确地说，是用索尼 PMD-222。我对磁带特别是那台机器有着特殊的感情。但说实话，磁带的音质其实一直不怎么样。所以当时大家认为磁带只适合用来录人声，比如记者在野外采访时使用。那是马克·马斯特斯。
He has a new book called High Bias about the history of the cassette. But because the cassette was so much cheaper and easier to use and portable, a lot of people didn't care so much about the audio quality, they just wanted to be able to use something that they could carry around with them. Portability was crucial to the success of the cassette. That's 99PI Engineer Martín Gonzales, who knows a thing or two about making things sound good. Cossettes weren't meant to be as high fidelity as vinyl or real to reels.
他有一本关于磁带历史的新书叫《高偏置》。但由于磁带便宜得多、使用更简单且便携，很多人并不那么在意音质，他们只是希望能随身携带一些东西。便携性是磁带成功的关键。那是 99PI 的工程师马丁·冈萨雷斯，他对如何让声音听起来美妙略知一二。磁带的保真度本来就比不上黑胶或开盘录音带。
They weren't meant to go where those other formats couldn't. The guy Lou Ottens who invented it, his first idea was I'm going to cut out a block of wood and put it in my pocket and see what feels comfortable and then I'm going to try to make a cassette player that matches that size. Cossets had another big advantage. They were much easier to record on. Before the compact cassette was introduced, recording anything was hard to do. The equipment was expensive, the tapes were expensive, it was easy to mess it up.
它们的意义在于去到那些其他格式去不了的地方。发明磁带的那个人路易·奥滕斯，他最初的想法是：我要削一块木头放进口袋里，看看什么尺寸感觉舒服，然后我要试着做一台符合那个尺寸的磁带播放机。磁带还有另一个巨大优势。它们的录音要容易得多。在紧凑型磁带问世之前，录制任何东西都很难。设备很贵，磁带很贵，而且很容易弄砸。
You kind of had to be sort of a semi-professional to be able to figure any of this out. The cassette wasn't really the best format in most ways, but it was the most useful format. Mark's book has stories of all kinds of cool scenes that were only made possible by the use of cassettes. Underground home recorded, lo-fi, and view-at. Early hip-hop blasting from New York City Boomboxes. A treasure trove of Cambodian tapes stashed away in the Oakland Public Library. But there was a chapter that made me realize there's one band that represents the ultimate triumph of the cassette.
你必须得半个半专业人士才能搞懂这一切。磁带在大多数方面其实并不是最好的格式，但它是最实用的格式。马克书中的故事记录了各种酷炫的场景，而这些只有通过使用磁带才有可能实现。地下家庭录音、低保真和录像带。纽约街头大喇叭里轰鸣的早期嘻哈音乐。奥克兰公共图书馆里藏着的一大批柬埔寨磁带。但其中有一章让我意识到，有一种乐队代表了磁带的终极胜利。
The Grateful Dead. Look, I am very much not a deadhead. Sorry to our listeners who are, but honestly, up until now, I thought they sucked. The music's fresh herein are solely that of Martin Gonzales and do not necessarily represent an MPI stature or serious exam. Alright, I've come around a little bit on them, but it's just, I was like, Mr. Cool Music guy, you know? I'm the type of a corner you had a party to tell you. Actually, my favorite
感恩至死乐队。听着，我真的不是“死忠粉”（Deadhead）。向我们的死忠粉听众道歉，但说实话，到目前为止，我都觉得他们烂透了。接下来的音乐纯属马丁·冈萨雷斯的个人观点，并不一定代表 99PI 的立场或严肃的审视。好吧，我对他们有点改观了，但怎么说呢，我以前觉得自己是个酷炫音乐达人，你知道吧？我就是那种会在派对角落里告诉你，其实我最喜欢的
Beach Boys song is the title track from their 1968 album Friends, which I think is probably the apex of their post-pets sounds there. Let's be friends. I thought the dead were for a very different type of person. You know the kind I mean. The ones whose natural habitat is in the parking lots of jam band shows. Old schoolies and people my age kind of living an old school
海滩男孩的歌是他们 1968 年专辑《朋友》中的同名主打歌，我认为这可能是他们“宠物之声”时期之后的巅峰之作。让我们做朋友吧。我以前觉得“死忠粉”是完全不同类型的人。你知道我指的是哪种人。那些天然栖息地在即兴乐队演出停车场里的人。老派嬉皮士和像我这个年纪、过着老派嬉皮士生活的人，他们就像是住在面包车里。
Hippie life where they're just like in a van. They're selling burritos there white and they have dreadlocks and they're like wearing no shirt and they're selling mushrooms out of a bag. That's writer and dead head Sophie Hagueney. Like a lot of people my age, I got into the dead biosmosis through like my dad, and then it was just like what we had in the car growing up. She knows what people think about dead fans. I approach loving the dead with some amount of self-deprecation just because I'm aware that it's not for everyone to listen to like endless jams. It can be, I think, really alienating for people who might not have a natural way in. My way into the dead was through cassettes. I found it so charming to imagine total strangers
他们在那里卖卷饼，皮肤晒得黝黑，梳着长 dreadlocks（雷鬼头），光着膀子，从袋子里掏出迷幻蘑菇来卖。那是作家兼死忠粉索菲·哈格尼。和许多我这个年纪的人一样，我是通过耳濡目染喜欢上感恩至死乐队的，比如通过我爸爸，然后这就成了我们小时候在车里听的音乐。她很清楚人们对该乐队粉丝的看法。我带着某种程度的自嘲来表达对这支乐队的喜爱，因为我知道并不是每个人都能听得下去无休止的即兴演奏。我认为，对于那些可能没有天然切入点的人来说，这确实会让人产生疏离感。我接触感恩至死乐队的切入点就是磁带。我觉得这种景象太迷人了：完全陌生的人
united by their love of this band, mailing each other tapes of shows that maybe neither of them even went to. But let's rewind the tape back to the beginning of the Grateful Dead. I gotta admit, this kinda rocks. What you're hearing is their first known live recorded from the January 1966 acid test.
因为对这支乐队的共同热爱而紧密相连，彼此邮寄着他们甚至可能都没去现场看过的演出磁带。但让我们把磁带倒回感恩至死乐队的最初。我得承认，这听起来还挺带劲的。你听到的是他们目前已知最早的现场录音，录制于 1966 年 1 月的迷幻测试（Acid Test）。
These were happenings thrown by Ken Keezy and his group, The Mary Pranksters. Everyone was dozed on LSD and there were crazy lights and experimental spoken word performances. The dead became the de facto house band. They became close with the era's most prolific producer of acid, Ausley Stanley, also known as Bear. He became the band's patron and first sound engineer, building gigantic high fidelity PAs for them. Bear started recording the band in his quest
这些是由肯·克西和他的群体“荒诞派闹剧团”发起的狂欢活动。每个人都嗑了LSD（麦角酸二乙酰胺），现场有疯狂的灯光和实验性的朗诵表演。这支乐队顺理成章地成了这里的常驻乐队。他们与那个时代产量最高的迷幻药制造者奥斯利·斯坦利（也被称为“熊”）建立了密切联系。他成了乐队的赞助商和第一任音响工程师，为他们打造了巨大且高保真的扩声系统（PA）。“熊”开始录制乐队的演出，以此来
to improve the quality of the live sound. They explained this in this 1991 interview. My way of doing that was to constantly play in the tapes back, listen to the tape, listen to the house, adjust them, listen to the tape. Listen to the house. After every show, we gathered in the hotel and played back the night skates. It was always a tape being made. Throughout the late 1960s, the dead expanded from their Bay Area roots and started touring nationally. They became a focal point for the counterculture. Their shows were never the same twice. They would make up the set list as they went linking songs together with extended improvisations. The magic of their live shows didn't quite translate into their studio albums. They released a few official live albums that were closer to the experience, but people really wanted
提升现场音质。他们在 1991 年的这次采访中解释了这一点。我这样做的方法就是不断回放磁带，听磁带，听现场，调整它们，听磁带。听现场。每次演出结束后，我们都会聚在酒店里回放当晚的录音。总有磁带在制作中。在整个 20 世纪 60 年代，感恩至死乐队走出了湾区根基，开始在全国巡演。他们成了反文化运动的焦点。他们的演出绝不会有两次完全相同。他们会边弹边即兴排定歌单，用漫长的即兴演奏将歌曲串联起来。他们现场演出的魅力并不能完全转化到录音室专辑中。他们发行了几张更贴近现场体验的官方现场专辑，但人们真正想要的是
to hear every show, to hear the differences, to hear if there might be something new they're playing, if there might be some new take on an old song. Intrepid fans would sneak in their own tape recorders and microphones to try to capture the elusive raw magic. Early tapers were mostly still using bulky real-to-reels. When the tape ended, you had to unspool the whole reel to switch tapes. It was a difficult and time-consuming process to do mid-set. And it wasn't quite accepted yet, so you might have to hide it somewhere, It was a difficult and time-consuming process to do mid-set.
听到每一场演出，听出不同之处，听听他们是不是在演奏什么新东西，对老歌是不是有什么新的演绎。勇敢的粉丝会偷偷带上自己的录音机和麦克风，试图捕捉那难以捉摸的原始魅力。早期的录音者大多仍在使用笨重的开盘录音带。当磁带录完时，你得把整盘磁带解开才能换带。在演出间隙做这件事既困难又耗时。而且当时这种做法还没被广泛接受，所以你可能得把它藏在某个地方，在演出间隙做这件事既困难又耗时。
And it wasn't quite accepted yet, so you might have to hide it somewhere, you might have to try to figure out a way to put a whole real-to-real deck like in your pants or something. Mark isn't kidding. Tapeers resorted to elaborate measures, like disguising a mic stand as a leg brace, or burying their gear in the stadiums field a couple days before the show. In those early days, illegal bootlegging was a widespread concern in the music industry. And at first, the band was opposed. The crew would confiscate the tapes or even snip their cables. The taping quickly became so widespread that the band came to a sort of grudging acceptance.
而且当时这种做法还没被广泛接受，所以你可能得把它藏在某个地方，你可能得想办法把一整套开盘录音设备塞进裤子里或者别的地方。马克可没开玩笑。录音者们采取了各种精细的手段，比如把麦克风支架伪装成腿部支具，或者在演出前几天把设备埋在体育场的草皮里。在早期，非法的盗版录音在音乐界是一个普遍存在的问题。起初，乐队是反对的。工作人员会没收磁带甚至剪断它们的电线。但录音的行为迅速普及开来，以至于乐队最终勉强接受了这种做法。
Here's the 1971 recording where guitarist Bob Weir and bassist Phil Lesh poked fun at a taper who is a little too close. Hey, you down there with the microphone. If you want to get a decent recording, you got to move back about 40 feet. It sounds a lot better back there, believe me. And Jerry Garcia had taped bluegrass shows when he was younger. So his philosophy was, when we're done with it, they can have it, you know. New York tapers formed clubs to trade recordings. They were the first to establish an important principle. The tapes couldn't be sold for a profit. You had to either swap for another tape
这是 1971 年的一段录音，吉他手鲍勃·韦尔和贝斯手菲尔·莱什在台上调侃了一位靠得太近的录音者。嘿，下面拿着话筒的那位。如果你想录出像样的音质，你得往后退大约 40 英尺。相信我，退后一点听起来好得多。杰瑞·加西亚年轻时也录过蓝草音乐的演出。所以他的哲学是：等我们用完了，他们就可以拿去听，你知道的。纽约的录音者们成立了俱乐部来交换录音。他们首先确立了一个重要原则：磁带不能拿来牟利。你必须拿它去换另一盘磁带
or simply give it away. The music was a communal resource to be shared freely. The band came to understand that people were taping simply to enjoy the music, not to make a profit. They also realized the tapes acted as free advertising for their concerts. And most importantly, they didn't want to be narks. The earliest cassette recorders were still mono and lower fidelity.
或者干脆免费送人。音乐是一种公共资源，应该自由分享。乐队开始明白，大家翻录磁带纯粹是为了享受音乐，而不是为了牟利。他们也意识到，磁带充当了他们音乐会的免费广告。最重要的是，他们不想当告密者。最早的盒式录音机仍然是单声道的，保真度也较低。
But throughout the 1970s, new higher fidelity portable cassette decks were released, made by brands like Nakamichi and Sony. Some even came with microphones. Tape-ing became more and more accessible. Suddenly with cassettes, it really all you had to do was pop it in the machine and hit record. There was almost nothing else to it. As the cassette spread, so did dead tapes.
但在整个20世纪70年代，中道（Nakamichi）和索尼（Sony）等品牌推出了音质更高的新型便携式卡式录音座。有些甚至还自带麦克风。录制磁带变得越来越容易。突然间，有了磁带，你所需要做的就是把它塞进机器里按下录音键。几乎没有别的了。随着磁带的普及，死之头（Grateful Dead）的录音带也随之普及。
When the band took a break from the road in the mid-1970s, the tapes kept circulating without them. By the end of the decade, the band was a cultural phenomenon. Caravans of deadheads would drive around the country following them around from show to show. At that point, cassette decks had widely replaced eight tracks in cars, so as you drove from one show to the next, you could listen to your dead tapes the entire way. The vibes never had to stop. Much like the dead's shows, every cassette was a little different. There are two main types of recording, soundboard and audience.
20世纪70年代中期，当乐队暂停巡演时，磁带却在没有他们的情况下继续流传。到这十年结束时，这支乐队已经成为一种文化现象。死之头的粉丝车队会开着车全国各地跑，跟着他们一场接一场地看演出。当时，汽车里的八音轨磁带已经被盒式录音带广泛取代，所以当你从一场演出开车到下一场演出时，一路上都可以听着死之头的磁带。氛围永远不会停止。就像死之头的演出一样，每一盒磁带都略有不同。录音主要有两种类型：调音台录音和现场观众录音。
This is a soundboard recording. It's clear, tight, dry, very little crowd noise. These were recorded by the Dead's Road Crew, though sometimes they'd provide a feed to friendly tapers. Some of these leaked out to the tape trading community, but most of them went into the archives and weren't heard until much later. Audience recordings were much more common. There's a lot less clarity, but you get more overall blend of the band, the room sound, and the audience. This one was recorded at Bob's recommended 40 feet back. I mean, this sounds pretty good considering it's just a guy who stuck a tape deck down his pants and hoisted a mic up above the crowd. In order to share the tapes widely, they would get copied over and over.
这是一段调音台录音。声音清晰、紧凑、干燥，几乎没有什么观众的杂音。这些都是由死之头的公路工作团队录制的，不过有时他们也会向友好的录音者提供音频源。其中一些泄露到了磁带交易社区，但大部分都进入了档案库，直到很久以后才被人听到。观众录音则要常见得多。清晰度要差得多，但你能更多地感受到乐队整体的融合、房间的音响效果以及观众的反应。这段录音是按照鲍勃推荐的距离舞台40英尺（约12米）远的地方录制的。我的意思是，考虑到这只是一个把录音机塞进裤裆、把麦克风高举在人群头顶的家伙，这听起来相当不错。为了广泛分享这些磁带，它们会被一遍又一遍地复制。
People would have dubbing parties where they'd all each bring a tape recorder and they'd chain them all together, and later dual-deck cassette recorders could make copies without needing a second machine. But those copies didn't sound exactly the same. Every time you made a copy, you would reduce the fidelity of the tape further and further. The sound degrades a little bit more every time and the tape hiss multiplies. That's called generation loss. So a pristine first generation soundboard recording.
人们会举行翻录派对，每个人都带一个录音机，把它们串联起来，后来双卡录音机不需要第二台机器就能复制。但这些复制品听起来并不完全一样。每次制作复制品，磁带的保真度都会进一步降低。每次声音都会多退化一点，磁带的嘶嘶声也会成倍增加。这被称为代际损失。所以，一张原始的一代调音台录音……
Sounds much worse after being copied just three times. You can hear it's way noisy. And if you copied it too many times, say, ten, it gets pretty rough. The music gets buried in noise and everything is all barbaric. Dead fans were willing to put up with these sonic drawbacks if it meant that they could listen to more dead, the sound even had an advantage over the official live albums. Cossets became associated with sort of a more authentic experience in a weird way. It didn't go to some recording studio and get polished.
仅仅被复制了三次，听起来就糟多了。你能听到它噪音很大。如果你复制太多次，比如说十次，情况就会变得相当糟糕。音乐被噪音掩盖了，一切都变得面目全非。死之头的粉丝们愿意忍受这些声音上的缺点，只要这意味着他们可以听更多死之头的音乐，这种声音甚至比官方的现场专辑还有优势。在某种奇怪的氛围下，磁带与一种更真实的体验联系在了一起。它没有去什么录音室进行精雕细琢。
It's just direct expression. This isn't something that's being passed through a lot of gatekeepers. All of this taping meant that deadheads could listen to virtually every single show. It led to this kind of extreme scholarship. Sophie Hagueney again. There's a kind of obsession with encyclopedic details,
这只是直接的表达。这不是那种经过层层把关的东西。所有这些录音意味着死之头的粉丝们几乎可以听到每一场演出。这导致了一种极端的学术研究。再次请索菲·哈格尼（Sophie Hagueney）来谈谈。有一种对百科全书般细节的痴迷……
but I think that it's really boring to hear someone talk for six hours about some minor point of some keyboardist from 1989. Unfortunately, if I were a deadhead, this is exactly the type of deadhead I would be. Dyerhard fans didn't just listen to the music. They collected it, organized it, and cataloged it. Labeling cassettes became an art onto itself. Fan magazine's published set lists and
但我认为，听一个人连续六个小时滔滔不绝地讲述1989年某位键盘手的某个微不足道的细节，真的很无聊。不幸的是，如果我是个死之头粉丝，这正是我会成为的那种粉丝。死忠粉不仅仅是听音乐。他们收集、组织并将其分类。给磁带贴标签本身就成了一门艺术。粉丝杂志会发布歌单和……
had classified sections,peer seeks tape. I talk to the person who, by all accounts, has the single largest collection, Mark Rodriguez, an artist who builds massive sculptures out of copies of dead cassettes. My collection probably around 13,000 tapes or so. That's going to be multiples or doubles and triples of certain shows. The dead channeled almost their entire artistic energy into their live shows. These tapes make them perhaps the most documented artist across any medium. Say if you had a video recording of Van Gogh visiting his studio every day and making his paintings and knowing exactly what brushes he used.
分类广告专栏，寻找磁带。我采访了公认拥有最大单一收藏量的人，马克·罗德里格斯（Mark Rodriguez），他是一位用死之头磁带的复制品建造巨大雕塑的艺术家。我的收藏大概有13000多盘磁带。其中会有某些演出的倍数或双倍、三倍。死之头将他们几乎全部的艺术精力都倾注在了现场演出中。这些磁带使他们成为跨越任何媒介记录最完整的艺术家。比如说，如果你有一段梵高每天拜访他的工作室创作绘画、并且知道他用了哪些画笔的视频录音。
You'd be like, oh yeah, like when he painted Starry Night on such and such a date, he used that Mongoose brush. We see their development, we get all the hiccups, we get all the flubs, we get all the successes. Dead fans can debate about the best versions of songs or best eras of the band, but because everything was captured, people sometimes even have their favorite detritus. Sometimes you want to listen to a song and you don't want to listen to the part where they're like, oh, the guitar is not really working that well, but I think that's also part of it. I like listening to Bob we're talking about like how hot it is in Oregon that specific time out like every time before it's been raining.
你会觉得，哦，对啊，就像他在某年某月某日画《星夜》时，用的是那支猫鼬毛画笔。我们看到了他们的发展过程，我们得到了所有的失误，所有的瑕疵，所有的成功。死之头的粉丝们会争论歌曲的最佳版本或乐队的最佳时期，但因为一切都被捕捉了下来，人们有时甚至会有他们最喜欢的残渣碎屑。有时你想听一首歌，但你不想听他们说“哦，吉他弹得不是很好”的那部分，但我认为这也是其中的一部分。我喜欢听鲍勃谈论那特定时间俄勒冈州有多热，而之前每次都在下雨。
I know this may be the first time I ever been to Oregon. It didn't rain now. It's 2-DM hot. It wasn't like Bob's off the cuff comment about the weather was meant to like live forever and yet it kind of does. I don't think the band expected that half a century later, people would be listening to their tuning and stage announcements. Jonathan D. Stevens of Boston University 036369705, valid only with current label. Your wallet is up here.
我知道这可能是我第一次来俄勒冈州。现在没下雨。热得要命。鲍勃随口对天气的评论并不是为了流芳百世，然而它在某种程度上确实流传了下来。我想乐队也没有料到，半个世纪后，人们还会听他们的调音和舞台串场。波士顿大学的乔纳森·D·史蒂文斯（Jonathan D. Stevens）036369705，仅在有当前标签时有效。你的钱包在这上面。
But people weren't just listening to the tapes for the music. It was a way of carrying the atmosphere of a dead show into your everyday life. The tapes were kind of a hang. Fast forward to the early 1980s. The set sales had finally overtaken vinyl. The newly introduced Walkman created the power to soundtrack your life at all times.
但人们听磁带不仅仅是为了音乐。这是一种将死之头演出的氛围带入日常生活的方式。磁带就像是一种聚会。快进到20世纪80年代初。磁带的销量终于超过了黑胶唱片。新推出的随身听让你拥有了随时为生活配乐的力量。
Meanwhile, the dead were bigger than ever. They chose to fully focus on touring and went seven years without releasing a studio album. Even casual fans were mainly listening to the tapes. That was the only place to hear new songs outside of a concert. But there was a problem. Some of these tapers were driving other fans' nuts. Another person they were driving nuts was Dan Healey, the Grateful Dead's longtime sound engineer.
与此同时，死之头比以往任何时候都更加红火。他们选择全心投入巡演，连续七年没有发行录音室专辑。即使是普通的粉丝也主要在听磁带。那是除了音乐会之外听到新歌的唯一地方。但有个问题。其中一些录音者把其他粉丝逼疯了。另一个让他们抓狂的人是感恩而死乐队长期以来的音响工程师丹·希利（Dan Healey）。
He told the story in a 1989 interview. Tapers got an inflated version of their own importance for a while there. They were beginning to lean on non-tapers who had seats that they wanted and stopped. One thing led to another and a concept of the taper section was like either band taping all together or organizing. So in October of 1984, the band set up an official taper section. Tapers would buy special tickets to sit behind Healey, where they wouldn't bother the other fans, who simply wanted to listen and vibe in peace.
他在1989年的一次采访中讲述了这个故事。有一段时间，录音者对自己的重要性有一种膨胀的认识。他们开始对那些坐在他们想要的座位上的非录音者施加压力，并且停不下来。事情发展到最后，设立一个录音者专区的概念就是要么大家一起录音，要么进行组织。因此，在1984年10月，乐队设立了一个官方的录音者专区。录音者可以买特殊的票坐在希利后面，在那里他们不会打扰其他只想安静听音乐和感受氛围的粉丝。
At that point, the band's finances were dire. For their entire career, they'd struggled to break even. Their ticket sales were massive, but so was their overhead. They started considering their tape vault as a potential source of income, so they hired a prolific tape collector to help them sift through the archives. Hi, my name is Dick Lahtvalla and welcome to the Gravel Dead Vault. In 1974, I started collecting tapes and then I did nothing else for about 10 years. Dick Lahtvalla had struck up a friendship with the band and the crew over the years.
当时，乐队的财务状况极其糟糕。在他们的整个职业生涯中，他们一直在努力维持收支平衡。他们的门票销量巨大，但他们的间接成本也很高。他们开始将他们的磁带库视为潜在的收入来源，于是他们雇用了著名的磁带收藏家来帮助他们筛选档案。嗨，我是迪克·拉特瓦拉（Dick Latvala），欢迎来到感恩而死档案库。1974年，我开始收集磁带，然后大约10年里我什么都没做。多年来，迪克·拉特瓦拉与乐队和工作人员建立了深厚的友谊。
Sometimes they'd slip him copies of Soundboard recordings. He and other tap, had long advocated for official releases of these tapes, but the band always thought they were too low-fi to put out. Eventually, they came around. In 1993, they released the first CD of the Dix-Pix series, which was an instant success.
有时他们会塞给他调音台录音的副本。他和其它录音者长期以来一直倡导官方发行这些磁带，但乐队总觉得它们的保真度太低而无法发行。最终，他们回心转意了。1993年，他们发行了迪克精选（Dick's Picks）系列的第一张CD，获得了巨大的成功。
The advertising played up the rawness of the tapes, recognizing that fans had come to see it as a virtue. By 1991 CDs replaced cassettes as the most popular format. Many tapers had also switched to digital recorders, but those were much more expensive and CDR burners cost thousands of dollars at the time. The easiest way to share the recordings from fan to fan was still the cassette. The easiest way to share the recordings from fan to fan was still the cassette. Jerry Garcia, the lead guitarist and co-founder of the band known as the Grateful Dead, died today, reportedly of natural causes. He was 53 years old, he'd been in for a car... The Grateful Dead split up in 1995 after Jerry Garcia's death, but the story doesn't end there.
广告大肆渲染了磁带的粗糙感，认识到粉丝们已经将其视为一种美德。到1991年，CD取代磁带成为最受欢迎的格式。许多录音者也转向了数字录音机，但那些要贵得多，当时CDR刻录机要花费数千美元。在粉丝之间分享录音最简单的方法依然是磁带。在粉丝之间分享录音最简单的方法依然是磁带。杰瑞·加西亚（Jerry Garcia），感恩而死乐队的主音吉他手兼联合创始人，今天去世了，据报道是自然原因。他享年53岁，他曾因汽车……感恩而死乐队在1995年杰瑞·加西亚去世后解散了，但故事并没有到此结束。
Similar taping networks sprung up around other bands. Dead tapes continued to circulate, and tapers still followed around the Dead's offshoots and solo projects. Deadheads congregated and communicated on the internet, which they've been doing since the invention of the internet. Their early home base was close to the Stanford Artificial Intelligence Lab, where many early internet protocols were developed. The lab was full of deadheads, and the bandwidth sometimes dropped by, too. One of the lab's first uses of email was to organize outings to dead shows.
类似的录音网络在其他乐队周围涌现。死之头的磁带继续流传，录音者仍然跟随死之头的分支和个人项目。死之头粉丝在互联网上聚集和交流，他们自互联网发明以来就一直在这么做。他们的早期大本营靠近斯坦福人工智能实验室，许多早期互联网协议就是在那里开发的。实验室里到处都是死之头粉丝，带宽有时也会受到影响。该实验室最早使用电子邮件的功能之一就是组织去观看死之头的演出。
As the internet slowly developed, deadheads were there every step of the way, from 1980s UZNet groups to AOL keyword dead. They're using the Internet to connect, but they still had to trade tapes and CDRs by mail. But it wasn't long before all physical media was rendered more or less obsolete by the MP3. In the early 2000s, fans embarked on a collective project to digitize and organize the recordings, which found a home on archive.org. Deadheads no longer had to cultivate their own personal libraries or track down rare recordings
随着互联网的缓慢发展，死之头粉丝无处不在，从20世纪80年代的Usenet群组到AOL的“dead”关键词。他们使用互联网进行联系，但他们仍然必须通过邮寄来交易磁带和CDR。但没过多久，所有物理媒介或多或少都被MP3淘汰了。21世纪初，粉丝们开始了一个集体项目，将录音数字化并进行整理，这些录音在archive.org上找到了家。死之头粉丝再也不用自己培养个人图书馆或去寻找稀有的录音了。
themselves. With one click, they could pull up virtually any moment from the dead's entire history. And if they had a tape that was missing, they could share it with the rest of the fandom. The Walkman couldn't compete with the iPod. The cassette simply wasn't useful anymore. And so people started getting rid of them. The tapes are literally kind of worthless. The value that they hold is really only sentimental
只需轻轻一点，他们就可以调出死之头整个历史中的几乎任何时刻。如果他们有一盘丢失的磁带，他们可以与粉丝群的其他成员分享。随身听无法与iPod竞争。磁带根本不再有用了。于是人们开始把它们扔掉。这些磁带简直一文不值。它们拥有的价值真的只有情感上的……
and for people who possess this particular obsession, they function more like literal memories like souvenirs than as collectors items. 2023 saw the last shows by the final incarnation of the great full dead. Dead and company featured a couple of original members, plus some other Jam Band veterans, and your body is a wonderland singer, John Mayer, standing in for Jerry Garcia. There were still tapers, but now fans could livestream professional recordings of every show. Taping was no longer a necessity, but more fans could livestream professional recordings of every show. Tapping was no longer a necessity, but more of a hobby.
对于拥有这种特殊痴迷的人来说，它们的功能更像是字面意义上的记忆——纪念品，而不是收藏品。2023年迎来了感恩而死最后化身的最后演出。Dead and Company乐队由几位原成员以及其他老牌即兴乐队成员组成，还有因演唱《你的身体是个仙境》（Your Body Is a Wonderland）而闻名的约翰·梅尔（John Mayer）代替杰瑞·加西亚。仍然有录音者，但现在粉丝们可以直播每一场演出的专业录音。录音不再是必需品，但更多粉丝可以直播每场演出的专业录音。录音不再是必需品，而更像是一种爱好。
Sophie saw Dead and Co many times, including their July farewell shows in San Francisco. The culture of going to a massive stadium dead show that includes original members of the band. That feels like it's ending. I can't really see what replaces that. And that's really sad. Like, I think I'm like, what will I do next summer? Sophie is not the taper type,
索菲看过很多次Dead and Co的演出，包括他们在旧金山的七月告别演出。去观看一场包含乐队原成员的大型体育场死之头演出的文化……感觉像是要结束了。我真的无法想象有什么能取代它。这真的很悲伤。就像，我在想我明年夏天要做什么。索菲不是那种录音者……
but of course she did have her phone. Phone cameras have turned us into a culture of compulsive documentaries, simply because it's so easy. I asked Sophie if she had any videos from that last show. I actually did not take very many phone videos, but I did, you know, I have some, so let me just see what I have. They weren't exactly Cornell 77. All my videos are like six seconds long in low quality.
但她当然有她的手机。手机摄像头把我们变成了一个强迫性记录的文化，仅仅是因为它太容易了。我问索菲她有没有那场最后演出的视频。我其实没拍多少手机视频，但我确实，你知道的，有一些，所以让我看看我有什么。它们绝对不是77年的康奈尔大学演出。我的所有视频都只有大约六秒长，而且画质很低。
Okay, you can't even really, that's fire in the mountain. Let's see what do we get here. ["The Fire in the Mountain"] ["The Mountain Mountain"] So there you go. She told me the clips were so short because she kept having a sudden realization. It's a familiar feeling to me and probably to you too. You're having a great experience, so you plug your phone and take a photo or
好吧，你甚至都看不清，那是《山中烈火》（Fire on the Mountain）。让我们看看我们得到了什么。["山中烈火"] ["山中烈火"] 所以你看。她告诉我，剪辑之所以这么短，是因为她一直有一种突然的意识。这对我来说是一种熟悉的感觉，对你可能也是。你正在经历一段美好的体验，所以你拿出手机拍张照片或……
video, maybe you've been posted right away. But then you realize, now I'm just looking at my phone. Documenting and sharing is so easy that it's become our new default, but this old man is going to shake his fist at a cloud right now and tell you, there is no way around it. Capturing a moment makes it harder to be in the moment. Dead cassettes are an artifact of when recording was rare and sharing took work. Tapers were volunteering on behalf of Deadhead's past, present, and future to try and capture every fleeting moment, to capture the entire moment,
视频，也许你马上就发布了。但随后你意识到，现在我只是在看着我的手机。记录和分享变得如此容易，以至于它成了我们的新默认设置，但我这个老头现在要向着天空挥舞拳头告诉你，这是无可奈何的。捕捉一个时刻让人更难置身于那个时刻。死之头的磁带是录音罕见且分享需要付出努力的时代的产物。录音者代表着过去、现在和未来的死之头粉丝自愿行动，试图捕捉每一个稍纵即逝的时刻，捕捉整个时刻……
not just the music, the feeling of being there. There's one place where cassettes are still the most useful format for music. We'll take you there after the break. take you there after the break. Back in 2016, we ran a story about a place where cassettes remained the most useful format. Documentary in Alex Lambert takes us there. The United States prison system has the largest prison population in the world. And when the more than two million prisoners in this country have access to music, it's often on cassette.
不仅仅是音乐，还有身临其境的感觉。有一个地方磁带依然是音乐最有用的格式。我们将在中场休息后带你前往。带你前往。早在2016年，我们报道过一个磁带仍然是最有用格式的地方。纪录片制作人亚历克斯·兰伯特（Alex Lambert）带我们去那里。美国监狱系统拥有世界上最多的囚犯。当这个国家两千多万名囚犯能够接触到音乐时，通常是通过磁带。
Well, my number one thing to keep around here is my walkman, my tape, my legal papers, and some bottle water. They had everything else. That's Adolfo Davis. At 14 years old, he was involved in a gang related shooting. He was tried as an adult in sentence to life in prison. Adolfo is 39 now and he's serving his sentence at Stateville Correctional Center in Illinois. Listening to music on tapes is one of his only means of escape. That's the only way I think I've made it so far because I have a good imagination. I just close my eyes to my ear buds and I just begun.
好吧，我在这里要保留的第一样东西是我的随身听、我的磁带、我的法律文件和一些瓶装水。他们拥有其他一切。那是阿道夫·戴维斯（Adolfo Davis）。14岁时，他卷入了一场与帮派有关的枪击事件。他被当作成年人审判并被判处无期徒刑。阿道夫现在39岁了，他正在伊利诺伊州的斯蒂特维尔惩教中心（Stateville Correctional Center）服刑。听磁带音乐是他仅有的逃避方式之一。我认为这是我能走到今天的唯一方法，因为我有很好的想象力。我只要闭上眼睛戴上耳机，我就开始了。
In 1990, the year Adolfo was incarcerated, everybody was listening to music on, because that tapes. In fact, Adolfo had some with him when he went to prison. Yeah, I got locked up with a Waltman and I think like seven tapes, yeah, when I was in the field, drugs, I have a fanny pack and I have my Waltman and my fanny pack with my tape. And I've been listening to the Waltman while watching out for security for the police.
1990年，阿道夫入狱的那一年，每个人都在用……听音乐，因为那是磁带。事实上，阿道夫进监狱时随身带了一些磁带。是的，我带着随身听被关进去了，我想大概有七盘磁带吧，是的，当我在街头贩毒时，我有一个腰包，我的随身听和腰包里装着我的磁带。我一直在听随身听，同时提防着保安和警察。
A fanny pack. Really caught up counts, but it's a fanny pack. Let's let's be real. Just a few years after Adolfo was locked up, the cassette tape would be all but replaced by the CD out here in the free world. But in prison, the cassette lived on. I've been telling my family, like, I need order to take the younger generations that I can tell you know the tape years.
一个腰包。真的抓得很紧，但它是个腰包。让我们现实一点。就在阿道夫被关起来几年后，在外面自由的世界里，盒式磁带几乎将被CD完全取代。但在监狱里，磁带延续了下来。我一直在告诉我的家人，像，我需要订购磁带，把年轻一代带进来，我可以告诉你，你知道，磁带岁月。
And not just any old cassette tape is allowed in prison. Some prisons require a very specific type of cassette tape. It has to be clear. It has to be sonically welded, so it can't be taken apart and put back together. And the box it goes in has to all be also be perfectly clear. That's Steve Step, owner of National Audio Company, America's pre-eminent manufacturer of cassette tapes. The reason you can't have a five-screw cassette or maybe a colored cassette that's opaque is they don't want a razor blade or narcotics or something else to be enclosed in a cassette. They do have people in the correctional facilities who look at and inspect incoming materials and they have to be able to see through or they won't allow them man. Steve has gotten familiar with this subfield of cassette tape manufacturing even though it is not
而且并不是随便什么旧磁带都能带进监狱。有些监狱对磁带有着非常具体的要求。它必须是透明的。它必须是超声波焊接的，这样它就不能被拆开然后再组装起来。它装在里面的盒子也必须完全透明。说话的是国家音频公司（National Audio Company）的老板史蒂夫·斯蒂普（Steve Step），该公司是美国最卓越的盒式磁带制造商。你不能使用五螺丝磁带或不透明的彩色磁带，原因在于他们不希望剃须刀片、毒品或其他东西被夹在磁带里。惩教设施里确实有人负责检查和检验进港物资，他们必须能够看穿，否则他们不会允许带入。史蒂夫已经熟悉了磁带制造的这个细分领域，尽管它不是
the focus of his business. Mostly he makes normal cassette tapes for a number of different markets. Music labels, spoken word, audio books. Steve's factory in Springfield, Missouri produces both blank tapes and tapes with audio already on them. The machines collate all those parts together, transfer them across on a conveyor, and then wrap them with cellophane and put a tear strip in. Steve was one of the first people in the cassette industry, and he's one of the only people still in it.
他生意的核心。他主要为许多不同的市场制作普通的卡带。音乐厂牌、有声读物。史蒂夫位于密苏里州斯普林菲尔德的工厂生产空白磁带和已经录有音频的磁带。机器将所有这些零件组合在一起，通过传送带传输，然后用玻璃纸包裹并装上撕裂带。史蒂夫是磁带行业最早的从业者之一，也是目前仅存的几个人之一。
We're the only people I know of. Most of the people left in the cassette industry are mom and pop shops or small operations. If you purchased a cassette recently from anywhere, from Radio Shack or from the merch table of some punk band you just saw live, it probably started out in Steve's factory. His company ships out up to 100,000 cassettes a day. And a small number of those cassettes are special orders for prisoners, made with clear plastic and without screws. Once the tapes leave here, we don't really see where they end up.
据我所知，我们是仅有的几家了。磁带行业剩下的多半是夫妻店或小型作坊。如果你最近从哪里买过磁带，无论是从Radio Shack还是从你刚看过的某个朋克乐队的周边摊位，它很可能是从史蒂夫的工厂里生产出来的。他的公司每天发运多达10万盘磁带。其中有一小部分是专门为囚犯定制的特殊订单，采用透明塑料制造且没有螺丝。一旦磁带离开这里，我们就真的不知道它们最终流向何方了。
That's the part of the business that we can't see from where we are. As for why cassettes have stuck around in prisons all these years, it's hard to get a definitive answer because every prison is different. But there's one theory we heard from a few different people. Tapes are allowed because CDs are easier to weaponize. They say that it's the most safest way for them to listen to music because a CD you could break and maybe cut somebody with. That's Chris Barrett.
那是我们身处此地所无法看到的那部分业务。至于为什么磁带能在监狱里保留这么多年，很难得到一个确切的答案，因为每个监狱的情况都不一样。但我们从不同的人那里听到过一种说法。之所以允许使用磁带，是因为CD更容易被改造成武器。他们说，这是他们听音乐最安全的方式，因为CD你可以把它弄碎，也许能割伤别人。那是克里斯·巴雷特。
This tape of him was recorded a couple years ago for a short film. Chris used to run a service that helped families and packages to people in prison in New York State. He had a warehouse full of items that had already been approved by the prison authorities. Everything from food, clothing, boxer shorts, and yeah, cassettes instead of CDs. But he never really understood the logic behind it. They let me sell tuna fish cans that, you know, you pull off the top and that thing is metal. Like, it's much more dangerous than a CD is my point to tuna fish cans and a CD.
这段录音是几年前为一部短片录制的。克里斯过去曾经营过一项服务，帮助纽约州的家属给监狱里的人寄送包裹。他有一个仓库，里面装满了已经获得监狱当局批准的物品。从食物、衣服、平角短裤，应有尽有，是的，还有用磁带代替CD。但他从未真正理解背后的逻辑。他们让我卖金枪鱼罐头，你知道的，你把盖子拉开，那个东西是金属的。我的意思是，金枪鱼罐头比CD危险得多。
So I don't know why they come up with some of the rules that they come up with. We just try to stay within those guidelines. Chris, whose package sending service recently went out of business, also sold a lot of cassette walkmans. Walkmans used to be available for purchase in prison commissaries, but they generally aren't anymore, which makes them extremely coveted items. I'm out of here, so I take your care of it because it is breaking like I start crying. And where and tear is not the only threat to the life of a walkman. But when it's like a major shakedown and they bring other officers from other institutions,
所以我不知道他们怎么会想出其中一些规矩。我们只是尽量遵守这些准则。克里斯的包裹寄送服务最近倒闭了，他也卖过很多卡带随身听。随身听过去可以在监狱小卖部买到，但现在通常买不到了，这使它们成了极度抢手的物品。我要离开这里了，所以我得好好保护它，因为它坏了的话我会哭的。而且日常磨损并不是对随身听寿命的唯一威胁。但当发生大规模搜监，他们从其他机构调来其他警官时，
they would just break your TV, break your radio, take your TV, take their radio, take those effects, once you destroy my walk, man, I cannot get another walk, man. It's probably one of the most prized items for theft. People try to hold eyes as much as they can, protect them as much as possible. That's Eifrin Paredes, Jr. He was a 15-year-old honor student when he was tried as an adult on a murder charge and sentenced to life without parole. He's always maintained his innocence.
他们就会砸碎你的电视，砸碎你的收音机，拿走你的电视，拿走他们的收音机，拿走那些物品。一旦你毁了我的随身听，我就拿不到另一个随身听了。这可能是最受垂涎的盗窃目标之一。人们尽量保管好它们，尽可能地保护它们。那是小埃弗伦·帕雷德斯。当他作为成年人因谋杀罪受审并被判处无期徒刑且不得假释时，他是一名15岁的荣誉学生。他一直坚称自己是无辜的。
Efren is 43 now, and during his 28 years in prison, he amassed a pretty big collection of music. Some of my favorites would probably be Kendrick Lamar, I like young GZ, Rick Ross, Nick Mills, I like young GZ, Rick Ross, Nick Mills, I like the way. At Muskegon Correctional Facility in Michigan, where E-Fren is serving as sentence, prisoners can actually have MP3 players. Inmates can purchase an MP3 player through the prison commissary and then download music to it through a kiosk provided by a company called Access Entertainment.
埃弗伦现在43岁了，在他入狱的28年里，他收集了相当庞大的音乐收藏。我最喜欢的一些可能包括肯德里克·拉马尔，我喜欢小GZ，里克·罗斯，尼克·米尔斯……在密歇根州的马斯基根惩教设施，埃弗伦正在那里服刑，囚犯其实可以拥有MP3播放器。犯人可以通过监狱小卖部购买MP3播放器，然后通过一家名为Access Entertainment的公司提供的自助终端将音乐下载到里面。
Before downloading, they have to transfer money to the company and receive a credit for a certain amount of songs. But there's a catch. And Michigan, there's a policy that they try to restrict as much music that would be labeled as parental advisory. In other words, the state of Michigan will try and sentence a 15-year-old as an adult, but when he becomes an actual adult, the state won't let him purchase music deemed inappropriate for a teenager.
在下载之前，他们必须向该公司转账并获得一定数量歌曲的积分。但这里有个问题。在密歇根州，有一项政策，他们试图尽可能限制那些被贴上“家长指引”标签的音乐。换句话说，密歇根州会试图判处一个15岁的孩子死刑或终身监禁作为成年人对待，但当他真正成为成年人时，州政府却不让他购买被认为不适合青少年的音乐。
It's interesting that the Department of Corrections has never taken any steps to restricting cassette tape purchases. We couldn't confirm that there were no restrictions on cassette music but Eiffren hasn't encountered them. And that's why he says a lot of inmates still prefer cassettes. They listen to them all the time, on their personal walkmans, and sometimes out loud. Actually, as we're talking right now, there's a gentleman in the bathroom washing clothes with his radio lines playing the song song play at your own risk.
有趣的是，惩教部门从未采取任何步骤来限制磁带的购买。我们无法证实对磁带音乐真的没有任何限制，但埃弗伦没有遇到过。这就是为什么他说很多囚犯仍然更喜欢磁带。他们一直在听，用他们自己的随身听，有时还外放。事实上，就在我们谈话的时候，浴室里有一位先生正在洗衣服，他的收音机里放着那首《自担风险》。
Rudder, the part of the prison where Eiffren is locked up, is the wing that houses the prisoners in solitary confinement. We hear guys all the time yelling up to us saying, hey turn the music on, turn some music on, turn on Turn Rick Ross on turn on me You know something so that they can hear down there Something that's you know music from upstairs I used to pray for times like this the rhyme like this so I had to grind like that the shine like this and a matter of time I spit on some like the, and the matter of time I spit on some like
鲁德，也就是埃弗伦被关押的监狱部分，是关押单独禁闭犯人的侧楼。我们经常听到有人向我们大喊，嘿，把音乐打开，把音乐打开，把里克·罗斯的音乐打开……你知道的，这样他们就能在下面听到，你知道的，楼上的音乐。我曾祈祷过这样的时光，写出这样的歌词，所以我不得不这样奋斗，像这样闪耀，假以时日，我会一吐为快，假以时日，我会……
the fish in the back of the penny wagon, cuz like the wrist, see my dreams unfold. Prison's tend to be late adopters of technology, so maybe one day all prisons in the US will just make the switch from cassette to digital, or maybe they'll go to CDs first just to be illogically chronological. Whatever the format, the most important thing about music to E-Fran and Adolfo is escape and connection. Here's Adolfo again. Music connects us all together. Everybody's shared music with each other. You know, music allows everyone to escape in this place.
就像便士马车后面的鱼，因为就像手腕，看着我的梦想展开。监狱往往是技术的晚期采纳者，所以也许有一天美国的所有监狱都会从磁带转向数字格式，或者也许他们会先转向CD，只是为了做到不合逻辑的年代顺序。无论采用什么格式，音乐对埃弗伦和阿道夫来说最重要的是逃避和连接。再次有请阿道夫。音乐将我们所有人连接在一起。每个人都与彼此分享音乐。你知道，音乐让每个人在这个地方得以逃避。
I can't, I can't do it without my music. In the days I rest my Waltman. I bought a walk man with somebody else to live stay with me. But I can go to sleep. But the days that you don't have your walk man? No, like I play my walk man like three days and I let it rest like two days. Well, he rests his walk man. That is love. Wow, he rests his Walkman.
我不能，没有音乐我过不下去。在我让我的随身听休息的日子里。我和别人买了一个随身听一起住。但我可以睡觉。但没有随身听的日子呢？不，就像我玩我的随身听三天，然后让它休息两天。好吧，他让他的随身听休息。这就是爱。哇，他让他的随身听休息。
That is love. That story was originally produced by Benjamin Walker and Alex Lampert, a slightly different version of the story aired on Benjamin Walker's degree of everything. Benjamin's got a new series coming out in January. That's going to be great because everything he does is great and groundbreaking. Go subscribe to the degree of everything. Benjamin's got a new series coming out in January. That's going to be great because everything he does is great and groundbreaking. Go subscribe to the theory of everything. Now.
这就是爱。这个故事最初由本杰明·沃克和亚历克斯·兰珀特制作，故事的一个略有不同的版本曾在本杰明·沃克的《万物之度》节目中播出。本杰明将于一月推出一部新系列。那一定会很棒，因为他做的每一件事都棒极了，而且具有开创性。去订阅《万物之度》吧。本杰明将于一月推出一部新系列。那一定会很棒，因为他做的每一件事都棒极了，而且具有开创性。去订阅《万物理论》吧。现在。
99% of his work was produced and mixed this week by Martin Gonzales, edited by Chris Barube, fact-checking by Graham Haysha, music by Swan Raal and Martin Gonzales. Mark Master's book High Bias is out now is so great you can also hear him on the Waste Boy's podcast, Mark Rodriguez's book after all is said and done is a gorgeous object. Thank you to Jesse Jarno, who provided editorial support. He co-hosts the official grateful dead Dead podcast and his book, Heads, is a definitive resource on psychedelic counterculture. If you're dead curious but don't know where to begin, our website has a list of which tapes to start with.
本周99%的作品由马丁·冈萨雷斯制作和混音，克里斯·巴鲁贝剪辑，格雷厄姆·海沙核实事实，音乐由斯旺·拉尔和马丁·冈萨雷斯创作。马克·马斯特的书《高偏见》现已出版，非常棒，你还可以在“废物男孩”播客中听到他的声音，马克·罗德里格斯的书《尘埃落定之后》是一件精美的艺术品。感谢提供编辑支持的杰西·贾诺。他是官方感恩而死乐队播客的联合主持人，他的书《头脑》是关于迷幻反文化的权威资源。如果你对感恩而死乐队充满好奇却不知从何开始，我们的网站上有一份可以从哪些磁带开始听的清单。
It's a public service right there, and if you tune in to channel 23 of 3SXM, you'll find the official Grateful Dead channel, all dead, all the time. 99% of visible's executive producer is Kathy too. Our senior editor is Delaney Hall, Kurt Colstead is the digital director. The rest of the team includes Jason Dalyone, Emmett Fitzgerald, Gabriella Gladney, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Leigh, Lashmiddon, Jacob Moltenado Medina, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, and me Roman Mars. The 99% of visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Stitcher and Sirius XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north
这真是一项公共服务，如果你收听3SXM的23频道，你会找到官方的感恩而死乐队频道，全天候播放感恩而死乐队的音乐。《99%隐形》的执行制片人是凯茜·图。我们的高级编辑是德兰妮·霍尔，柯特·科尔斯特德是数字总监。团队的其他成员包括杰森·戴利昂、埃mett·菲茨杰拉德、加布里埃拉·格拉德尼、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、维维安·李、拉什米·多恩、雅各布·莫尔特纳多·梅迪纳、凯利·普赖姆、乔·罗森伯格，以及我罗曼·马尔斯。《99%隐形》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。我们是Stitcher和Sirius XM播客家族的一部分，现在总部位于向北六个街区处
in the Pandora building, and beautiful. Uptown, Oakland, California, home of the Oakland Roots soccer club of which I am a proud community owner. As other professional teams leave, the Oakland Roots are Oakland first, always. You can find us on all the usual social media sites. We are not on Letterbox, but Chris and Martín keep telling me it's the only good social media. You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love, as well as every past episode of 99PI and 99PI.org. Okay, here's none. Stitcher, serious ex-sum, Stitcher, I'm too sweaty I can't do. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
位于奥克兰潘多拉大厦，美丽无比。加利福尼亚州奥克兰市上城，这里是奥克兰根基足球俱乐部的大本营，我是该俱乐部自豪的社区老板之一。随着其他职业球队的离开，奥克兰根基队永远以奥克兰为先。你可以在所有常用的社交媒体网站上找到我们。我们不在Letterbox上，但克里斯和马丁一直告诉我那是唯一好的社交媒体。你可以找到我喜欢的其他Stitcher节目的链接，以及99PI和99PI.org的每一期往期节目。好了，没有了。Stitcher，严肃的前奏，Stitcher，我太出汗了，我做不下去了。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。